oh he pooped yeah without the baby
shooting out oh no without the diaper
did you guys get dirty
luca
are you giving your grandparents a hard
time already
oh my
baby
good morning
okay so
i'm all ready to go casey went to go get
the car and we have mama and mama and
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know the tones are
really hard
they're going to be taking care of luca
today because it's casey neis
anniversary we have an adventure today
so
oh my goodness
my baby boy i love you bye guys have fun
oh okay oh it's a poop diaper right yeah
i'm gonna mark it we gotta keep track of
these things
okay bye
we are celebrating
our how many years 10 years
10-year being together anniversary
five-year wedding anniversary i went
back to the room because i forgot the
most important symbol of our marriage my
wedding ring
you got yours there we go yeah oh my
gosh i miss luca already i miss isaac
too i wish he came on this trip with us
but he still has school what are we
doing today we're going on a helicopter
tour it's gonna be my very first time on
a helicopter and also my very first time
seeing the grand canyon because we're
gonna get to see the grand canyon i'm so
excited
thank you it looks very nice
i decided to you know try a little bit
you look really nice too we match with
our stripes we don't even coordinate on
purpose that's cute i love it happy
anniversary
it was great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh that was an experience i
almost cried when we first started
taking off because i'm like oh my god
this is something for my bucket list i
get to do right now with you to
celebrate our anniversary oh my god this
is amazing it's like way more wobblier
than uh than uh
airplane yeah that's what it's called
yeah
airplanter it literally felt like
someone just like picked us up like i
don't know it was like yeah that was so
cool though oh my gosh and my favorite
part was right when we were about to get
to the airport and we had to like do
this turn and like see the whole strip
turning in a helicopter is really fun
yeah because you're just so like you're
so like it's like a roller coaster i'm
on a high right now
i love getting to do it with you and
like getting to like experience new
things together like
10 years in and we still get to have our
adventures
now we're gonna head back to the hotel
and check up on luca yeah i'm not gonna
lie though i'm really nauseous right now
oh yeah you were nauseous if i was an
action hero
i would not jump on helicopters
i'm really proud of myself actually
because i
i found my way back to i think our hotel
without using gps i noticed i was like
oh you know where you're going kind of
cool yeah we gonna turn this way it's on
this side right now i think it's this
way you guys
over here you're right oh you know it's
funny that the five-star the helicopter
companies right in front of us oh yeah
we could have paid extra for them to
give us a ride but we're like we're
gonna work for our fly mates yeah our
trip mates
say it again
we're already laughing though that was
hilarious he said ortella mates
i'm a hella mate
that was funny i missed it because i
stopped recording we are back
back
look at this boy were you behaving luca
yes yes
we ate
we slept
mama sent us pictures too let me show
you look she said that one
and we sent that
and she said this one when he was
sleeping and we took selfie too i know
in the mirror
this is the very first time in his
entire life he's staring in his entire
life that we've ever left him without
one of us being with him either good
like how could you
okay
[Music]
is it fun for you or is it like weird
for you to um
look after my kid after having tooken
that taken after or raised me
yeah it's been like 20 something years
you know after taking care of kerry
it's not like riding a bike you have to
like relearn a little bit yeah
yeah like i had to like relearn
everything for luca it's only been 14
years i can't even imagine like 30
no 20 27 28 28 years yeah yeah yeah what
about you saying saying that's what i
did too look at him
so mom's been doing all the work it was
funny because when he hold he held him
for a little bit he's crying and then
and then i picked up and then i hold him
and he stopped crying he said i was good
thing you know you're picking up is no
crying there was somebody here who was
called crying on cranky you know and
then she took over and then she stopped
crying all right oh that's good
[Music]
10 years later
this guy joins us 10 years later yeah
that's how i met your mother
that's not even how how we met you want
to hear the story
it all started when i met your aunt
rabbit robin robin
and what did we go do
we went to go eat korean bbq and that
was our first official date our first
official date yeah
and after that we're like oh maybe go
hang out at our friend's house who's
house sitting for someone else and
that fell through it would have been
quite an experience had we done that but
that that would have changed the course
of this date yeah and instead we went
back to my place and we just had like a
little one-on-one time yeah we put on we
put on super bad super bad it was super
bad that's right yeah you busted out
your guitar and you played a song for me
i did play a song yeah see i wouldn't
have been able to serenade you had we
gone to this other place
[Laughter]
yeah who would have known those people
10 years from then what have you in
their lives
they're so crazy
isn't it
i mean i don't know
it was so cute because
when we went to go eat have dinner the
last night that
all of us were together because isaac
went to school the next day he actually
asked to hold luca so he could take a
family photo i'm like what because he's
always afraid of holding luca but for
this family photo he actually held him
he's so cute
being with him like all the time i
can't smell that new baby smell but then
you end up smelling anything we only
left for like two hours we're so
exaggerating it's like oh my god we've
been apart for so long like days and
months and years it was only like two
hours that was the first time we left
you completely without a parent
wait i didn't know the difference yeah i
slept through it like that wasn't you oh
okay i think it was hilarious that
mama's first diaper changed with us
being gone she got sprayed yeah or no
she caught it but like well that shows
how much of a pro she is yeah
we got the best in the business to
grandma you to grandma are you
[Music]
where are we going it's fun
time we actually i forgot swimsuits
yeah we bought them got some sunsets
yeah i actually i did bring my swimsuit
but i forgot at the hotel
so here we go it's our anniversary gifts
to each other because they're very
expensive they are and so is this place
oh wait we've been here we've been here
before yeah i remember this
[Music]
your steps in already
oh they do have swimsuits here oh nice
maybe you don't like these ones doesn't
look good that was cute
[Music]
oh my god the spa was
to die for i have never had a massage
that made me want to cry because it was
so good like that's how bomb that
massage was and then
we actually took a nap together for like
a whole hour
and that was nice it was an hour
we were just taking a nap there just
playing there yeah we're just walking
around
it's been a really
nice relaxing adventurous delicious day
i forgot to get a shot of that but that
is really really good well here's half
of it oh here's half it oh perfect just
put that with this together
and you gotta you get you get the idea
there we go and we got this you get the
idea of this one we haven't touched it
yet so we are at
placebo sugar cane
for dinner it's like papa's like fusion
so we got raw hamachi pizza look at that
that looks so good
awesome thank you thank you
what is that case all right this is the
thing that caught my eye the most on the
menu the waffle
the duck and a fried duck egg oh that's
good yeah the egg is gigantic the big
yolk you know this whole time i've been
trying to get this thing on my fork
i can't do it yeah we finished our uh
our martinis and what'd you get we got a
mexican lemon drop okay yeah we're
pretty uh we're pretty good i just
checked up on luca
he's sleeping it's already his bedtime
he had a great time with mama
congratulations congratulations yeah
thank you
insert the video clip that she just sent
us with your dad
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
so cute i love it
[Music]
bye
[Music]